all right with me now in the hood our
distinguished engineer Larry heck of
Microsoft Research and general manager
at Bing experiences Mike calcaneal and
they're gonna tell us all about the
research is going into Cortana the new
personal assistant for Windows Phone 8.1
Larry Mike thanks for being here this is
gonna be fun and I don't want to get off
on the wrong foot but there's already
some other popular popular personal
assistant phones out there there's the
one that Suri I think people have heard
of the less chatty sibling Google now
what makes and this is whatever he's
gonna be wondering what makes Cortana
different better than our counterparts
yeah well I'll take that I think you
know the the first thing that we you
know set out to do was really you know
we we didn't overly focus on you know
products that were already in the market
I think Google now Siri they're actually
excellent products they're useful right
our goal was really to you know build
something useful ourselves right it's
like you know I don't think we set out
with a with a goal and building Cortana
to you know knock off Siri or knock off
Google now our goal was really to make
the phone better right so I think
there's you know in so far that they do
interesting things I think there's some
natural overlap in terms of like you
know what we think an assistant should
do I do think we made some different
choices in terms of you know what we
envisioned assistant to be right what we
where we wanted the assistant to go and
some of the you know kind of design
choices we made or around how how we
actually realized our on the phone the
biggest difference I would say it's like
if you look at the you know kind of
space together is that we've really
modeled Cortana after the interaction
model that we've developed with Cortana
really is that of a it's a real
assistant right we uses a North Star you
know the metaphor of having a real
assistant right a competent personal
professional assistant so you could use
and count on to get through your day
right and so things like the notebook
right things like you know what the
assistant can do right away for you
right the the ability to of the
assistant to confirm with you right you
know where she should start where she
should stop what she should know right
we really think that you
that's a it's a design choice that we
made early on that will you know not
only I think this is differentiate what
we what we have in the market now but I
think it'll also cause the assistant to
kind of like take its own course right
as we as we develop it over time
absolutely and obviously we saw some of
court on display this morning during the
opening keynote and it's fascinating to
see where it's going and what all of
this is doing let's talk about the
research that's gone into realizing the
Cortana advantages as we're calling it
Larry what can you tell us about the
speech recognition research that Cortana
utilizes yeah so the speech recognition
research that's been done here and at
other places has been evolving gradually
over time 20 years of investment at
Microsoft Microsoft research on speech
recognition and a lot of the advances in
speech recognition has been due to data
and and figuring out how to get data fed
back into into the systems and this is
all based on teaching the computer how
to recognize speech by giving it
examples so called machine learning so
that's been a big foundation for many
years and speech recognition it's it's
that kind of technology is also being
now used in other components that you
need to pull off something like like
Cortana that speech recognition is only
one of those pieces you know as you
recognize speech you have to then
understand what the person is talking
about and so for that natural language
understanding is another component it
sits on top of the speech recognizer
then you have to figure out what you
want to do with it whether if the person
is asking you for directions Cortana has
to decide okay well you know this is
relevant information about directions I
want to give that you know show a map
for example and that's taken care of in
the dialogue manager component and then
there may be some speech output back to
the user to to say okay these are the
directions to the you know closest
Starbucks to you so there's a Texas
speech synthesis as well so this all
these different technologies that said
with speech recognition that are
required to pull off something like
Cortana and you need to have investments
in research and all of those for many
years to kind of pull
until how you know for folks watch how
is this speech recognition different
from the powers and other personal
assistants are using well I think a lot
of like I say a lot of advancement
speech recognition is depending on the
data and how much data you have that's
fed back into the system and the quality
of data that you have fed back and you
know the amount of data that we're
getting right now we're pulling back
particularly from being search voice
search is tremendous and you know we're
extending speech recognition
capabilities also into Skype and Skype
translator for speeches speech
translation so that there's you know
speech recognition that occurs when the
person is talking and let's say English
and then translation and then synthesis
into let's say German well all of that
data on the translator side and the
voice search side and Cortana side and
all the other speech applications feeds
back into the single recognizer that we
use across the board across for the
whole company so I think one of the
things that's an advantage for us is
that we have so many different you know
scenarios and products are out there
that that feedback into this speech
recognition technology I know a lot of
the folks who joined us online today
probably have either only heard of
Cortana or only seen a snippet and
seeing and hearing is believing so let's
say we jump into a little demo yeah sure
be happy to don't have a lot of time to
show off the full features I thought for
a second I might be able to show off any
alright so this is just my normal
Windows Phone 8.1 right it's a Lumia
icon I can get to Cortana one or two
ways I can come in through what we call
a live tile or I can actually just hit
the search button here as you can see
here I'm kind of greeted by Cortana the
spinning circle is kind of her
personality in persona mm-hm and then
peeking up through the bottom here this
is the information that the Cortana has
for me it's information that based on
her knowledge of me she's prepared for
me in advance so for instance you see on
the screen you know it's only you know
3:00 o'clock 3:30 but you know Cortana
thinking like well this is probably you
know around the time where you know Mike
might be wanting to go home right so uh
he's laughing because he knows I never
go he hasn't yeah that's right
but yeah so you know actually it has my
current location it has a suggested
traffic route and he'll told me it'll
take if I leave right now 26 minutes in
order to get home and then if I scroll
up you can see other things that she's
gotten for me one thing that I do is I
you know here's some you know suggested
places around here that I might want to
go after work maybe instead of going
home
some stocks I'm looking at some news I'm
a fan of the San Francisco Giants I
actually use Cortana the track Cortana
and this notion of the notebook I you
know we find that right here it's like I
can actually if I want to tell Cortana
something about hey I'm not interested
in San Francisco Giants anymore or if
I'm interested in another team or
another thing I can actually go into the
interests look over the information that
she actually has on me right and make
some adjustments so you can see here
she's tracking some you know flights
that I'm gonna be on soon right um you
know stocks and I'm interested in she
knows I'm interested in eating and
drinking and the best nearby right so
that's kind of like the Cortana and the
notebook and how she keeps track of my
interests and of course he can also
speak to her yeah you know one of the
three here yeah sure I think you know
just in general the way we attached the
kind of like there the way we attack the
kind of speech fart is that you know the
primary thing that we really wanted to
enable Cortana to do like a real
assistant is to help you get through
your day you know so putting things on
your calendar knowing where you have to
be reminding you to do things so I can
actually use Cortana to set you know
person time or place based reminders
right so going through the same entry
point I can say remind me to call my mom
when I get home so here you can see that
yes so Cortana actually knows where I
live right she knows that my home is
this particular you know kind of like
what we call it geofence right that
reminder will trigger when I actually
pull into my driveway or I get a nice
little under on my phone says call my
mom Wow we've also built Cortana on top
of Bing so I can answer just you know
questions that you would expect of a
search engine all right so what's the
weather this weekend in Paris
on Saturday in Paris there'll be cloudy
skies with a high of 80 and on Sunday
there will be mostly sunny skies with a
high of 72 so what I like about that
particular example is like you know
rather than just getting you know 10
blue links or getting even yeah right no
five-day forecast you actually knew that
I was asking for you know the weather
this weekend it she gave me that exactly
there's a lot of meteorologists who are
not happy about that yeah let's try it
just started sweating yeah and then back
to what we're doing differently I'll
just show one more thing it's like you
know one thing that we really wanted to
do with Cortana and it sounds like kind
of fun and games but we actually think
there's a serious reason behind it is we
really did think it was important to
imbue her with a very engaging and
specific personality right so one of the
things you can actually do with Cortana
is you can ask her anything right and
we're continuously kind of like evolving
her personality and updating this stuff
right so that we we feel like it serves
two purposes one is it helps connect the
user to you know kind of their assistant
and helps them build a relationship
around trust and it's also just
entertaining and fun well the fact of
the matter is this Cortana is a real
person right she's not a real person and
most people don't think she's a real per
night right I think but there's a real
voice behind it there is a real voice
behind it so let me just I'll demo it
and then we'll talk about the voice yeah
right so do you sleep so are you honest
answer yeah we get we get answers like
that so the voice that we actually have
is so that audio actually comes from the
cloud right it's part of our service
that powers Cortana and the the voice
actress that we asked to record that is
actually the same actress that records
the character Cortana in Halo really
yeah so I'm lucky enough to live in the
Seattle area where Jen lives and I've
worked with her before so any day now
maybe a year from now and Cortana is in
everybody's pocket it's gonna be the
greatest thing to say hey I know her
she's a local gem yeah she's a local
guys this is great stuff thank you so
much for popping by and showing us what
you're up to this is very exciting
appreciate